In a time of social division, we often
hear about how politics drives us apart.
But we never really hear about what
brings us together. Well, it turns out
some pretty simple things can help, like
living in a community rich in amenities
such as grocery stores, parks, libraries,
bars and restaurants — even gyms! A recent
AEI survey finds that people who live
within a walking distance or a short
drive from a grocery store, park, or
favorite restaurant know their neighbors
better than people who live farther out.
People who live close to their favorite
bar or restaurant, gym, or theater are
much more likely to rate their community
an excellent place to live than people
who have to drive more than 15 minutes.
57% of people who walk to their grocery
store talk to their neighbors several
times a week, compared to just 42% of
those who have to drive more than 15
minutes. Now, it may not be a panacea, but
where we live and how we design our
communities might just be a good first
step toward hating each other less and
maybe learning to get along a little bit more.
What about your community do you like most?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.